humph gum resumes pure okay the
mainstream this is a bright new horror
game but it's an alpha just we'll have
to point that out
all right here we are I have man breasts
SS and an ash cashmere sweater and we
are ready to party breasts oh there you
are
it's actually kind of cool why might why
do I throw away my flashlight
why would I ever throw it away Aloha I
have the force look at this [ __ ]
come here [ __ ] let's open this door
hello
out in the wild earnest as a ship but oh
god what is that
okay oh good what is that
no dubstep monster other than my least
favorite type of one says Oh God hip
Socratic classes and all kinds of [ __ ]
alright
what is that what did I do
what's in here Oh ghost X I missed you
man let's party - baby - kotora - kotora
- kotora - kotora - kotora - kotora -
kotora - oh god this [ __ ] i swear to
god this table set monsters what nope
nope I don't want to I'm fun it had a me
what is a dubstep man Stan just when you
thought he was safe from Deb said
monsters just when you thought he was
safe alright close the door
alright he doesn't like me that's one
thing for oh whatever - [ __ ] Amaka
yeah how do you hey if I teleport I'm
sure it'd be fun to come on okay we're
just gonna have to find our way to offer
[ __ ] sake
for [ __ ] sake man this is so uncool
this is so uncool it's so uncool oh god
I can't handle
oh the the cameras is using the cameras
oh my god I should have known I closed
it up place yeah
oh so the calm rest trigger him wonder
[ __ ] full what is in here a radio oh I
took that [ __ ] with my apparently
submarine arm
I love submarine arms they're my
favourite type of arms how did I do that
so you need to you need to stop doing
that with your arm I don't know what it
is you're doing with your little majiggy
but hello I can hide Oh what is this
yo Inc that's amazing I think you can do
in the future man so I hide I hide like
this Amma's in what am i doing in the
ceiling did I fall out the mat oh god is
coming isn't he oh God
oh oh oh oh yeah that makes sense
well at least I have my man breasteses a
Russian surgeon did that for me very
very good I can recommend you brace if
you need mine if you need to man
breasteses whoo oh we're out oh my god
ah you're so fry I feel so very fry oh
I'm not going back in there screw that
let's finally captain's new cabinet log
or now no now what a shitty surveillance
system now we're on the other side of
the bed
but with which bed can you trust Oh God
what is this place I found some duct
tape
I love duct tape now I can tape my face
so he won't hear me screaming awesome I
have duct tape in my butt that makes me
their fire extinguisher oh I will spray
your ass that needs a little spruce true
spritz prone you yeah that's a good
spray spray what I'm sorry you can have
the fire extinguisher you can have my
flashlight you can have everything I
believe I can fly
that doesn't make ha ha ha ah he doesn't
know how to do that
he doesn't have pepper a mess oh [ __ ]
well you [ __ ] up now didn't you hide
no I didn't stop clown yeah hey man how
you doing that's he doesn't even manage
to talk what an ass
uh-huh what an ass okay now I know how
to use the flashlight does a good job me
yes more glow sticks more glow sticks
equals more party more party equals more
glow sticks this is the way of life I
know for a fact there's more duct tape
hiding underneath are you duct tape ha
found you dare you are duct tape thank
you combine me duct tape
yeah my new best friend acting have you
ever been with a man mr. duct tape
now I haven't pitched oh really
well once we free from this boat I'm
gonna teach it to all kinds of places
duct tape I really pills yes talk dirty
to me pills I thought that's what I was
doing but do it my baby you turn me on
you're still looking so fine it's thank
you
okay all right I'm sorry duct tape
you're gonna have to go you're gonna
have to serve as bait
you [ __ ] pants I'm sorry don't look
at me like that glow stick don't you
dare look at me like that
he knew the river fun hell vector table
picked Abba Father yokai aura humble
slaughter I'm a slow Abdullah mind God
minecraft notch notch do something what
the [ __ ] is so fast I don't know what to
do that's a limit to every man and
that's a bad mine I don't think I don't
want surprised right so in this game we
accomplished a lot of things hope you
enjoyed watching Brice this game is
still in alpha but I still hope you
enjoy watching it looks promising it
looks fun it's definitely scary so
that's all this implies it's a scar coma
birthday see Bros in the next video stay
awesome I'll be Bros ready